well world leaders are yet to decide
whether they will recognize a taliban
government in afghanistan but
inside the country some are already
saying they will cooperate and joining
us now is afghan politician
ghani he is the grand council chieftain
of afghanistan's kachi nomads and also
brother of exile president ashraf ghani
mr ghani thank you so much for talking
to us on sky news do you support the
taliban
not really i've accepted
in the afghan population what choice do
we have
do we go fight another war on behalf of
someone do we become a pawn on somebody
else's proxy award we've got no choice
in this stage all we can do is stay back
try to save out the lives of our people
you know i'll give you a simple uh
example if you go around the villages of
afghanistan
and you look at their cemeteries they
are half and half most cases half of
uh
afghans killed that served in the
military
and half of them those taliban that got
killed fighting there
but who did we fought for and
all the promises that we got basically
we got betrayed by two people
mr trump by
calling up on taliban
in
doha and agreeing to leave the country
and by then putting the final nail on it
it's interesting you say that the west
pulled the rug out from under your feet
people will argue um what has your
country what has your government been
doing for the past 20 years why have you
not be built been building it up there
has been so much money poured into that
country why when they did pull out
whatever nature that pull-out
took
why did it collapse so spectacularly and
so
quickly actually from the beginning uh
the country's uh
uh the embassies from zama khalifa is as
an ambassador to everybody else
everybody tried to divide the government
and allocate the portion to those that
they
serve their own personal interests or
the countries in
so it was a divided uh government over
and over i've been one of the best
predicts of it even though i was closely
related to the uh usher and then i was a
close friend of karzai but i never uh
stopped criticizing that they brought
half-educated afghans from abroad that
simply just had a foreign passport
they didn't put
any emphasize on
it recruiting the top afghan educated
abroad or anyone else we were totally
lacking in on the
you know on any relationship
that would build some sort of a
correlation
or
exact focus on the technocrats
on intellect on the business community
it was all a location
uh the if you remember the prts it was
50 million dollars a month
in the province mostly going to the
pockets of uh a few people
roads and all that built that were where
it didn't needed it uh the
private contractors security a lot of
that money that came in if you look at
it maybe five to ten percent of it end
up in afghan game the rest of it all
flew back out of it so it was uh from
the beginning first of all afghanistan
as uh
if you jokingly look at it we live in a
bipolar society i'm going to jump in
there
i'm going to jump in there
because you're saying it's so divided
right or it was so divided so do you
think the taliban could actually be a
unifying force in leading your country
forward if you do support them
i have not
i've told them frankly look and i've
openly said this that they know security
because they were the one fighting it so
they should be able to and once they
stop fighting the security
should be a question and security is the
basis but without
economy without foreign relationship and
without the help of intellect and that
and without an open society to the world
that is the new afghanistan it will be
very difficult for them to
to rule as well okay just briefly we've
got this 31st of august deadline no one
seems to know what's going on about that
you've got the taliban saying there will
be consequences if they stay
if they do stay
what do you think will happen
i think the taliban will be provoked
so
they didn't do it in an ordinary matter
i mean some embassies did it beautifully
uh you can look at the netherlands uh
you look at the turkish the pakistanis
helped
some of them they could have even cigar
which was part of the american operation
it used the afghan kabul intercontinent
all these people
look at their document put them in a
proper pass and deliver them the british
have done it
too to a certain level in a better
manner compared to what the americans
have done
they
could have cooperated with the taliban
they could have picked up
a look at a huge location such as their
embassies or some place close to the
airport and they could have done it in
orderly manner this is totally insulting
to those people
that
were the brain
of the of gods
and to see them
leave in such a disgraceful
manner it's beneath them
okay mr ghani thank you so much for
talking to us